[Music]
why is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
but you really don't remember
[Music]
how's
[Music]
hey
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
blue
[Music]
[Music]
but she was more like from a movie
she told me her name is
[Music]
who would dance
young mother always
[Music]
my son
[Music]
[Music]
get advice
[Music]
be careful what you do go around
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my son she says
[Music]
she just said
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
just a small town girl
[Music]
he took the midnight train
[Music]
no
[Music]
it goes on and on and on and on
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and on and on
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
don't stop believing
[Music]
don't stop me believing
[Applause]
[Music]
still
don't stop
oh
up
[Music]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
oh
can you feel it coming in
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
the last
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president
of the united states donald j
[Music]
trump
who gave that light to me and i gladly
stand
up next to you when they met her
still today but there ain't no doubt i
love this land
bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to lane
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
i know i'm free and i won't forget
the men who died who gave that life
to me and i gladly stand up
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
that's a lot of people let's see here
early in the day
that's a lot of people they've got
themselves a big big
surprise coming don't they huh it's like
four years ago
except now we've done it all so now you
know you know before i'd come and i'd
say we're gonna do this we're gonna give
you tax cuts we're gonna rebuild your
military
we're gonna give you a regulation cuts
the biggest in history
but now we've done it all so now you
know it's not just talk
the others all talk no action this is
not fair
we've done it we've done so much hello
pennsylvania eight days from now
we are going to win the commonwealth of
pennsylvania and we are going to win
four more great years in the white house
all right
our opponent sleepy joe biden
[Music]
you heard it the other night at the
debate did anybody see the debate
that's where he said uh there will be no
fracking right no energy
how about a million jobs from
pennsylvania forget about it
his agenda is one of doom and gloom and
depression and despair he's right now
locked in his basement he's
he's put the lid on you know the lid on
the garbage can that's what they thought
somebody said he's going to make his way
out you know he sees we had a tremendous
crowd before we have another one
of these and you know those uh well i
love you too
i don't know who she is but she sounds
very nice
she sounds very nice
thank you very much thank you very much
no no he saw what went on
two hours ago at another location in
pennsylvania
and he said we better get out i don't
think he said it his people said his
handlers they said
listen uh sleepy joe we got to get you
out of the basement
so they just announced you know this
morning they announced they're putting
the lid on you know the lid
and i hear it's for five days five days
that's 50 percent of the campaign
no but they just announced we had a
tremendous one i mean
just a lot of love right and they just
announced
he's leaving to make a speech you know
he's going to make it in delaware he
always makes it up
about three minutes from his basement
got to get them out that's why they got
to get them out they see what's
happening you know our polls are through
the roof and
the fake news is look at all those
people but
[Applause]
they don't like to report it
they don't like to report it our agenda
is one of unlimited optimism
opportunity growth patriotism prosperity
and true american pride that's what we
have that's what we have
you heard him the other night this is
going to be a dark winter no it's not
going to be a dark wind
going to be a great winter it's going to
be a great spring
for the last half century joe biden's
been
outsourcing your jobs right here in
pennsylvania
you were one of the biggest victims of
it opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood and treasure in
endless foreign wars they just never
ended countries you've never even heard
of
now joe biden and we're bringing them
all back our boys and
young women are coming all back
now biden is trying to ban fracking you
heard it the other night oh
it was so nice he almost made it through
the debate i was a little surprised
it wasn't great but he was fine and then
we talked the energy question and he
forgot
he forgot now we want to wean ourself
off energy oh
that's not so good and i said texas are
you listening pennsylvania are you
listening
now he's going to ban fracking because
he has no choice his party wants to ban
it
he's going to ban fracking and deliver
an economic death sentence
from pennsylvania for many other places
in our country and frankly it affects
not just places that frack
and oil territory you know who it
affects everybody
having to do with paying an energy bill
how about the two dollar gasoline for
your car that's not bad right
remember remember what it used to be 5
50.
nobody uh saw an engine site we uh we
have it to two and even sometimes below
at the same time
we saved our great companies
our energy we're number one in the world
now by far number one in the world
[Applause]
and pennsylvania is a big big part of it
in last week's debate
joe biden confirmed his plan to abolish
the entire
u.s oil industry i said you mean no more
oil joe
well that's what i mean
i felt like perry mason you ever watched
very mason that last
little it was always the last minute i
did it i did it yes i did
i was very basic no oil joe
she even said why did you say that
kristen who was very good actually i
thought she was good a lot of people
thought she was tough i thought she was
very good
i thought she was i've been considering
that
it was sort of supposed to be two on one
from day one right but we've had that
we've had that from the beginning
haven't we huh
and here we are here we are
no i thought she was good but she said
that right she said why did you say that
why and that's when he really got into
trouble
that means no fracking no natural gas no
jobs
no energy for pennsylvania families
he will eradicate your energy and send
pennsylvania into a
crippling depression and that's what
you'll have if this guy gets in with the
biggest tax cuts and
he look i gave you the biggest tax cuts
in history
he wants to give you the biggest tax
increase
in history once they raise your taxes by
the most ever
think of this all my life i've been
watching politicians
we will give you a tax cut we will cut
your taxes
we will cut them we will cut them this
guy is running against me
we will raise your taxes who the hell
ever heard of that
i never heard of it uh
this could only happen to me
and then you have biden's running mate
how about her kamala
[Music]
she's considered america's by far most
liberal senator she's
more liberal than crazy bernie can you
believe it
even sponsored the 100 trillion dollar
green new deal which will destroy our
country
totally destroyed no planes no cars no
cows right no cows
cows are next they took it out but only
temporarily
they don't like cattle of any kind
and it's a plan for economic suicide 100
trillion
if our country did great every year for
100 years
we'd lose a fortune at 100 trillion you
couldn't make that much
no matter how well we did if everything
was going on all 12 cylinders
100 made up by aoc plus three
a great student of the environment i
don't think she ever took an
environmental course in college
she did go to college right but i don't
aoc
plus three i heard she was very upset
that i was calling her aoc
plus three three is her friends her
three friends that know
less than she knows joe biden is a
die-hard globalist
who wiped out your steel mills closed
down your factories killed your coal
jobs
outsourced your industries and supported
every
horrible terrible ridiculous
trade deal for over half a century think
of it 47 years plus
he was a cheerleader for nafta the worst
trade deal ever made
and i ended it remember i used to say
we're going to end and everyone smiled
they said hey look
give it a shot i got it then nobody
thought i could get that
and usmca just kicked in and it's
incredible for our country less for
their countries but that's okay they're
happy
sort of not too happy he
enthusiastically voted for china's entry
into the world trade organization that
was beginning that was the beginning of
the china rise
that was a disaster they were flatlined
for years and years and then
bump thank you very much joe i
appreciate it joe
joe and others decimating your
manufacturing and enriching china
at your expense you know that you know
that
china is considered a third world
country
and for purposes of that it's considered
a developing country
so they have all sorts of advantages
over us in this horrible horrible
world trade organization but we just
want a seven and a half billion dollar
lawsuit
because they know i'll pull so fast out
of that mess that is such an
unfair deal and all of a sudden we're
winning
all of a sudden we're winning cases
seven and a half billion
seven and a half billion they're not too
happy about it
no but think of it they're considered a
developing nation i said so we're a
developing nation too we're developing
they're developing we're developing
they get big advantages nobody ever said
obama never said anything
sleepy joe never said that i'm the one
that figured it out i said how come
they're getting all these great deals
well sir they're considered a developing
nation whereas the united states is
considered to develop they say we're not
developed
you've got to be kidding me they
wouldn't develop we want to be a
developing nation also
and so we're having a big dispute world
trade
and how about the well world health
right so we were paying
500 million a year china was paying
39 million a year china had more access
and more power within the
uh the realm than we did so i said let
me ask you a question
number one they were wrong on almost
everything i don't want to knock them
but they were wrong on
the pandemic they were called a lot of
shots wrong almost everything
they were in china's pocket i said just
out of curiosity let's get down to
dollars
why are we 325 million people
why are we paying 500 million
and why is china paying 39 million and
china has more power
within than we do so if you don't mind
i withdrew from the world trade from the
world health
from world health i withdrew from world
health
and i promise you one thing if we ever
go back we can go back for much less
money
that i can tell you you don't pay 500 no
but seriously
so they have 1.5 billion people they're
paying 39.
right we have 325 we're paying 500.
other than that it's a wonderful
transaction
i say oh we have hundreds i could talk
to you all day about it like we have
hundreds of things just like that
pennsylvania lost 50 percent of its
manufacturing jobs after
biden's nafta and this china disaster
that we signed
[Applause]
a decade after decade vote after vote
biden betrayed pennsylvania he betrayed
our country
through sheer stupidity even his
secretary of state
who was also secretary of defense said
he never made
the right decision on foreign events on
foreign deals on foreign anything
he never made the right decision on
economics
the guy doesn't know what the hell he's
doing do you finally understand this
he repeatedly tried to cut social
security and medicare you know
i think we have of course a hell of a
lot of money we're only doing this for
very important groups
see that screen up there costs a lot of
money look at these cranes over there
holding up the flags
i hope they're being donated by the
crane company
for the good publicity they're going to
get but that's a lot of power holding up
their flags but you know what
our flag deserves a lot of power doesn't
it
now after years of economic treachery
sleepy joe biden wants to ban fracking
and that's what he is that's what we
have the types remember he said oh
plenty of time
this guy went for a full year we were
banned fracking we were banned fried
like a hundred times i could have this
thing running for hours
i'd just show you a couple when it goes
on
cecil b demille when it goes on right
i'll just show you a couple
but he went for a whole year we will ban
fracking ban fracking
then he got lucky elizabeth warren
decided that she wanted to hurt her
you know her person were the
philosophies of saying so she stayed in
think of it
elizabeth pocahontas warren she would
have
all she had to do is get out before
super tuesday and joe would not have won
any state right wouldn't have won a
state she took the votes away from crazy
bernie
and you know bernie is the best
sportsman i've ever seen
he loses all the time and he's happy he
goes back into congress oh
is bernie running again in four years
does anyone know the press look i'll ask
the fake news
well they'll give you a fake answer
no it's true he's a he's a tremendous
loser he is a tremendous lizard
but he did us some big favors you know
we had a lot of bernie's people come
with us last time because they agree
with me on trade
they couldn't have done what we did but
they know that we were being taken
advantage of by
foreign countries many of whom are
allies you know they keep saying we
don't treat our allies right well they
don't treat us right either
we got to remember that they don't treat
us right you don't have to take my word
about his record
just take a look at this magnificent
tape that we made for you
for the people of pennsylvania and it
really pertains to you
so much go ahead my problem is i voted
for nafta
i'm supporting nafta because i think it
is a positive thing to do
and i do not pretend to be an expert on
international trade matters when you ran
for president
and when barack obama ran for president
you both said you would renegotiate
nafta
you didn't trade agreements like nafta
and permanent normal trade relations
with china which forced american workers
to compete against people who are making
pennies an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160
000 jobs the president is absolutely
right when he says
that china has been cheating for 25
years and that bill clinton
didn't do enough about it george w bush
didn't do enough about it barack obama
didn't do enough about it what
how exactly are you going to negotiate
that what magic wand do you have
the rising china is an incredibly
positive development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
as our competitor we should be helping
the idea that china is going to eat our
lunch
is bizarre the idea that they are our
competition
they're going to beat us is bizarre
china is going to
eat our lunch come on man they're not
bad folks folks
china's not a problem allowing china
into the world trade organization
which he supported extending most
favored nation status to china which he
supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us oh do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
today we're finally ending the nafta
nightmare and signing into
law the brand new u.s mexico canada
agreement very special listen it's hard
to overstate the importance of usmca
this is the single biggest bipartisan
legislative victory for this president
and this administration
it is a huge deal wage growth is better
than it has been since 2009.
that means it is better than it has been
for seven out of eight of the years that
obama was president
the new usmca has powerful protections
to keep
auto manufacturing jobs since the
election we've created
41 000 brand new motor vehicle and parts
jobs
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the usmca
is better than that it is better than
that
never said i oppose frackie you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website put it on put it on the website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in the bottom
administration
no it would we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee you we're going to end
fossil fuel
no more no new fracking
i'd gradually move away from fracking
and i think it's critically important on
day one
that we end any fossil fuel leases on
public lands
like what about say stopping cracking
and stopping pipeline infrastructure and
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil
fuels
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking
i have one final what would he close
down
or would you close down the other way i
have a transition from the oil industry
yes
oh transition that is a big in terms of
business
that's the biggest thing because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas
i remember that pennsylvania
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
goodbye pennsylvania thank you very much
make sure you vote properly doctor
i don't what do i have to speak about
okay he's going to destroy your economy
i mean he said it and then he says you
know he lies
he goes and says for a year it will be
no friend then he goes and he says
they'll be fracking because he comes
here
somebody explains that you have a
million jobs in fracking
and he goes oh i didn't know that oh
well i never said that
for a year he said it many many times we
only put four or five versions of it up
we could have had him
we could have kept you here all day and
by the way barack hussein obama showed
up too you know how many people he's
drawing at these rallies
like he's drawing flies 20 30
40. not quite this crowd
oh did you see the other day you see the
other day mr congress has been a great
congressman
we had he had 41 people but the press
never shows that
they show him speaking now with me i
want the opposite i want them to show
this crowd you know in the middle of the
day
on a monday
what a beautiful raining
i mean it's amazing right middle of the
day it's incredible no
here's 41 people there 22 people and he
gets up and then they say
oh he's so rhetorically good i never
thought he was a good speaker person
i really never did and they say he's so
handsome
he's so answered oh
but they don't want to show you know
what they don't want to show they don't
want to show us crowd
they don't want to show the crowd and
you know what they don't want to show
this crowd for the exact opposite reason
because this is amazing and you know
what honestly
no matter where we go wisconsin ohio
north carolina we have crowds nobody's
ever seen crowds
in the history of politics there's and i
say it
knowing that oh they'll change it in the
history of politics
and you know we have pennsylvania dutch
don't tell anyone you know they uh
they're great people they're great
people but they're not known for going
out and voting
for rotary don't tell anybody but the
pennsylvania dutch
are voting and mass
[Applause]
i heard that the other day they said we
can't have a man who sleeps say hi they
work hard we can't have a guy that
sleeps all day in the basement we can't
we like trump we like trump that's great
thank you there's a little relationship
there you know a long time ago a little
relationship there
hard workers incredible craftsmen you've
done work for me over the years i'll
tell you
they can throw up a barn in about two
days
[Applause]
they can throw it up and they use the
wooden cogs they don't use screws
because they want to make everything
themselves right
and that is the most beautiful place
really you do great work thank you very
much we appreciate it
in 2016 pennsylvania voted to fire this
corrupt far-left political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting
america first
with your vote we will continue to fight
for american workers
nobody's ever fought harder lower drug
prices
i instituted it favored nations laws the
drug companies do not like me
you're going to have a 60 70 80
drop in drugs you know last year was the
first year 52 years that drug prices
went down
they went down very little but they went
down 52 years but that's the peanut
stuff
the big stuff is favorite nations they
are not happy
big farmer most powerful you know
lobbyists they spend money like it's
water
they are spending more money on me right
now than sleepy joe and commercials big
pharma
because we pay the highest prices in the
world
and i said i want to favorite nations
where we matched
we match now the lowest country in the
world so we go from the highest
to the lowest because i'd instituted
something that nobody thought
anybody would ever do
and they want to make a deal you know
they all get paid like 35 million a year
they're very smart
i used to say i'm gonna if you don't cut
your drug prices i'm going to institute
favorite nations oh we don't mind that
sir we don't mind that we don't mind
that when i did it they went crazy
they're good poker players but they want
to make a deal so let's see maybe we'll
make a deal maybe we won't but uh
in the meantime you have favorite
nations i'm telling you i see the great
jeffrey lord there is that jeffrey lord
you're going to drop
jeffrey formally of cnn and then he
became a trump guy and cnn said we got
to get this guy off
we got to get him the hell out of there
you look good jeffrey
you look good he's been a great guy
actually he was he was in a hostile
territory for a long time
but he knew what was right he always
knew what was right thank you very much
we want to support our police protect
our great second amendment
defend our borders and ensure more
products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa we're doing that
[Music]
remember when i campaigned four years
ago i said we will be saying merry
christmas again we do
[Music]
remember the department stores they
didn't like merry christmas that was not
politically correct
oh yeah we they learned and it's a happy
new year and they'd have the card and
the snow and the whole thing but they
wouldn't say merry christmas
they're all saying merry christmas again
that's
the way we have that i told you that
we will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth and a safe vaccine that
quickly ends the pandemic which is
ending with or without and we have the
vaccines they're going to be very
nobody would have them it would be years
before you had them what i did with
fda and fda's been terrific but it was
called a slightly speedier process okay
and totally safe we will have the
vaccine like
momentarily and we're all set to
distribute it before the end of
the year maybe substantially before but
it's going good
but we are going to get ourselves back
to normal life i said normal life
where we were seven months ago we had
the greatest economy in the world
we have the greatest economy in the
world we want to get back to exactly
that
and we're in a super v right now you see
the numbers the housing numbers the
automobile numbers all the numbers the
way they're coming back
at a level that nobody's the job numbers
11.4 million jobs in a short period of
time
we will be back very quickly we'll never
forget what china did to us that was
no we will never ever forget you know i
signed a great trade deal with china
they ordered the largest
it's the largest order of corn largest
order of soybeans beef
cattle ever a few weeks ago
because they want to keep us happy they
want to keep us happy
but you know what we're not happy we're
not happy
what they did just they could have
stopped it they stopped it from going
into china
the rest of china wuhan and they stopped
it
but they didn't stop it from going out
to the world and that includes us in
europe and every other place 188
countries
next year will be the greatest economic
year
in the history of our country you see it
all happening
and watch you know pennsylvania is a
late voting state
by the way you know you vote late and i
love
that i love that i like voting a little
late because you can see what we're
doing we've done an incredible job with
a lot of different things but
you're gonna have a gdp number the
atlanta fed said
now the highest i think was eight
percent nine percent it was not
you know it was it was high they
projected 35 percent
increase in gdp nobody's ever had that
[Music]
i'll take 25 right now okay they
projected a 35
and that number will come out on
november 1st right before the election
so if you'd like to wait
everybody here's sure about trump but if
you happen to be a little bit uh nervous
just wait and we're going to have a 35
percent or
25 but it's going to be magnificent
because we are doing great
it's the greatest come back anywhere in
the world economically
and we went down the least of any
country in the world
so remember that i gave working families
record-setting tax cuts largest tax cuts
in history and in my second term i will
cut middle-class taxes
even more we're cutting the middle
income taxes very substantially we're
doing another cut
and what it does you know to be honest
it brings more business
it brings more jobs you have to see in
terms of what we did for business
companies are pouring into the united
states
joe wants to take all of the regulations
that we took off
20 years to build a highway with
environmental and all
20 years no they want to take them and
they want to put them all back
now we have it down to two years to
build a highway and it could be one but
and it may be that you don't build it
because of
uh environmental or safety and that's
okay but you're gonna know fast right
you're gonna know fast and you will
build it but you're gonna know fast
20 years we have much worse than 20
years we have highways that have taken
22 23 years and then never got approved
how about that you go work on something
for most of your adult life and then
they reject it at some
environmental board three to two now
we're going to do it in a year we're
getting it down to a number that's
and by the way it's going to be much
less expensive
much better we have highways that
started as a straight road
from here to here that ended up like
this
it costs 100 times more much more
because it took so many years
and we're not doing that anymore we'll
put it in we'll either get it approved
or not get it approved it's a big impact
that's one of the reasons that
our foundations are so strong that's one
of the reasons that we can make a
comeback nobody else can make a comeback
like
us we have the greatest country in the
[Applause]
world
thank you
so we gave you the biggest tax cut in
history
by far and biden is proposing
the biggest tax hike in history
okay which will that will lead to a
depression like you've never seen this
is
a terrible thing by the way this is the
most important
election in the history of our country
remember that
because you have a radical left movement
that wants to make us a large-scale very
large-scale version of
venezuela or so many other countries
with the same philosophy
and it can happen you know 18 years ago
venezuela was a very
rich beautiful powerful place now they
don't have food they don't have water
they don't have medicine they have
nothing
nothing they have oil it's worthless the
whole thing is like what's happened
this would be a very very large scale
version of the same thing and it can
happen
when you see these people and what they
want to do it's the same thing
it's all the same thing doesn't matter
the size we're much bigger
but it'll happen we can't let it happen
this is the most important and i never
thought i'd say it
because what we did all together most of
you are with us four years ago
nobody thought that anything could ever
be more important as an election than
that
this is now the most important election
we've ever had
it's a choice between a trump super
recovery and a biden depression and it
will be a depression it's a choice
between
a trump boom and a biden lockdown he
wants to lock down the country
we understand the disease we have to
take care of our
older wonderful people are elderly
especially if they have heart problems
diabetes problem in particular different
problems
and we do that but look i mean i got it
and i'm here right great
we have great medicines now great great
therapeutics and first lady got it and
she's doing great
but you know you know who else got it
baron my very tall son got it
she's definitely tall he's very young
he's very tall and he's strong
and you know the doctor said sir i here
to inform you
baron has tested positive i said tested
positive for what
and they go corona they go you know
there's about
30 different names right for this i call
it the china virus because that's where
it came from
the china plague no barrett has tested
and i said wow that's very bad well he's
going to be good so 99.9
right 99.99 so i said how are you
feeling very good why what's the problem
he didn't even know
he said the doctor like two minutes
later how's baron doing oh he's okay sir
he's
fine i said what do you mean he's fine
it's gone
the young kids they have a strong immune
system i've gained such respect for them
they have a much stronger system than we
do whether we like it or not
so it's one of those things but we have
to do that and it's incredible but
we will we have made such strides it's
absolutely an amazing thing what we've
done in a period of seven months
because you know i'm the president of
the united thank you very much
i'm the president of the united states i
can't lock myself in the basement of the
white house
i can't i can't lock myself in a
beautiful bedroom in the white house
upstairs i can't do it
i can't do it because we have things to
do we have people to meet and
i'll have meetings sometimes i'd have
meetings with a lot of people
that were pretty much unavoidable if
you're the president i mean you can go
and just lock yourself away you can't do
that
and i'd leave those meetings and i'd say
even with gold star families you know
they're looking for it for months and
months and
they lost their son or their daughter or
their husband or their wife
and you can't cancel that and i say
boy and i'm not referring to that so
many of the meetings i'd have i'd say
that's a little risky right that's a
little risky and then one day you get it
and that's okay you get better we have
such great i think cures
regeneron i mean to me that was like a
cure i don't know maybe it would have
been fine without it
but let's say i didn't want to take a
chance you know if i have my choice
i'll do whatever i often tell though i
tell the story but you know when you're
president you have a lot of doctors
and i had 12 and the best he's great
uh sean from the white house doctor is
fantastic he really is
they're great talented people and walter
the walter reed hospital is incredible i
see what they do to our young
incredible soldiers that come back with
horrific injuries and they
they do a job and johns hopkins and
i'm sitting in bed and i'm saying i
don't feel so good doctors
and they say uh i say where are you all
from and i get a list of those who of
the world right these 12 guys
and they each he says and they each
thank you very much
i think that's a compliment but they
each have like a specialty
and i'm sitting around and i'm sitting
around i'm laying there and i want to
get the hell out but i'm not feeling the
best i've ever felt i haven't been used
to that
and all of a sudden hands go all over my
body
i got these 12 guys they examine every
part of your body you wouldn't believe
it i said get the hell out of here i
want to get out of here
but i took regeneron and the next
morning i felt like superman i felt
well mom
i said i gotta get back i gotta get back
you don't want a president that's
laying in the hospital saying oh we
gotta get back right
and people get back 99.9 i mean you know
and this state has to open up
the commonwealth of pennsylvania you got
to get it open you have a governor
who who by the way has made it
a governor named wolf i'll remember i
remember
you know on my last site he got them to
close it up
we've had a lot of problem getting sites
they believe in freedom of speech of
course but we've had a lot of problems
with this guy
because you know in the last one we had
to move around different sides he was
watching they don't want to
they don't want us to speak and this is
the guy who's in charge of balance right
in this state
so what do you think he's going to do
with the ballots right and this is the
guy that we just sued
because they don't want to have poll
watches in philadelphia so why don't
they want to have poll watches what's
wrong with people watching
the votes they don't have they don't
want to have poll watches
if joe biden and the democrat socialists
are elected
they will delay the vaccine delay the
therapies prolong the pandemic and close
your schools and shut down your country
hate to say it you are
shut down anyway pennsylvania
pennsylvania you're gonna have to either
get a new governor he's gonna have to
open it up
don't worry on november 4th on november
4th he will announce we have decided to
open up pennsylvania
oh that's true i had the same thing in
michigan we actually sued michigan and
the constitution they
opened it up they said she was
unconstitutional what she was doing she
was running it
like a prison camp except for one person
who was it her husband
her husband gets caught going out
boating and all sorts of stuff he was
the only one that was allowed to do
whatever he wanted
but no she ran it too it was terrible
what was happening in michigan and by
the way we're up in michigan we're
leading
i i have here i have here
and the only reason i'm doing this
remember i used to do it all the time
four years ago i got to start doing it
again because they give you fake phone
numbers
so rashmir said which was very accurate
great paul
had us at 53 and 52 we're at 52
history says that at 52 you don't lose
right
we're at 52 they don't want to report it
you know any poll that comes out
positive they don't put it on
i've been told by pulsars why don't you
get it out
it's a great poll sir we do get it out
they will not report it
these people are the most dishonest
people
so ready different polls
we're leading in nevada we're leading
big in texas you don't hear that
we're leading big in ohio remember you
must win ohio
in fact i hear they left ohio they've
given up ohio
we're leading big in ohio jim jordan is
a good guy right jeff
we're leading by four points in florida
you didn't hear that did you
[Applause]
we're leading by infinity in utah and
west virginia we're leading but i forget
it i won't even
we're leading by a lot of utah we're
leading by 20 points in
west virginia 20. in georgia we're
leading by
four points and i think it's much more
by the way four points and then we have
jeffrey wright the hidden voter
a lot of you people are hitting voters
they'll say who you voting for
leave me alone just leave me alone
that's what happened remember they
thought that i lost because the exit
polls
and people would ask about you know
they're coming out most in history by
the way
the most in history did leave the poll
they voted four years ago
and say who did you vote for you know
these arrogant stupid people
who did you vote for it's none of your
business
so they'd mark it a blank and then
another one who did you vote for
some of them would say i voted for
hillary clinton is that okay and they
didn't they bought it from me
they said i voted for crooked hillary
clinton okay is that all right
so to say okay hillary clinton who did
you vote for
none of your business there's another
word there's another two words that are
much more effective
who do you vote for
but i won't say it if i do that the
campaign is over
right she's saying don't say it please
sir i promise
and i've learned i've learned we can't
even kid with these guys we can't get
it's a lot of them though there are a
lot of them on a rainy day in
pennsylvania middle of the day
so so what happened
is i was told a number of people call
sir i'm sorry to
tell you that it's looking very very bad
oh wow
why and i had gotten home from michigan
made a speech at one o'clock in the
morning it started so it's election day
with 32 000 people and she had made a
speech
prime time seven o'clock and she had
500. i said why are we going to lose
michigan
hadn't been won in decades by republican
i said i think we're going to win but
anyway we get back and we did you know
we won michigan we're
leading michigan again by the way
according to this
we're leading a lot of places that they
don't talk about they don't want to talk
about it
you know it's suppression they want to
convince you they want to depress
you they want to suppress you they want
you to think gee let's not vote
we love our president but let's not vote
because he's not going to win
well they tried that last time and it
didn't work and it's going to work even
i mean our numbers are much better this
time than last time so
you're going to but jesus you got to
vote i almost hate to tell you because
you'll say oh
now i don't have to vote he's winning
right now you got to go out and vote
but but i'll never forget that that
evening where
i was told sir no sir
i'm sorry but not looking good because
they took all those people which was
like 42
that says none of your business
essentially in different forms
and they didn't count them and they
didn't realize that every one of those
people that said that was our people
and then all of a sudden i get a call
like an hour and a half later from a
real pro who's with me right backstage
bill
and he goes sarah these are great
numbers sir
you're going to win florida sir you're
going to win north carolina sir you're
going to win pennsylvania
he's a political cause
and you know when i got the first call
from a great person but you know it was
very
felt badly because we worked so hard
when i got the first call i went in to
see our great first lady he was a great
person i said first lady
i said first lady sometimes referred to
as melania
i said you know it's not looking good
it's not looking good first lady we
worked hard
and you know what's funny i thought it
wasn't going to make it but one thing
unlike joe
where he goes into a basement if he
loses and you know who knows what
what happens right it's called an
election he should be ashamed of himself
because he didn't work
and no seriously he didn't work one
thing i did
five six and sometimes seven of these in
one day those last few days
and during the regular time i do two or
three today
today i'm doing three of these
tremendous crowd waiting for us at
another point
this is the second
so when they told me that information
you know you feel badly but i didn't
feel bad
because i left it you know the athletes
they say
we left it all in the field it was all
left and i did six or
seven that day six or seven of these
this is not like talking in front of ten
people right
there's a lot of people here and i did
them from early in the morning till
one o'clock in the morning the next day
which was election day so i didn't feel
but then what happened
so i told the first lady i said not
looking good she said do you mean
we lost i said it looks like it then i
go on about an hour later
first lady i got news for you i think
we're going to win
because uh they didn't isn't it sort of
an amazing thing but they didn't
say that they had this tremendous record
set of numbers you know when you leave
people
usually say i voted for this one that
when i vote but we had a record set of
numbers jeffrey we had a record set
where they just said it's none of your
business we don't want to tell you and
all of them were
our votes and this was the only guy that
figured it out so we had
one of the most exciting evenings in the
history of this world let alone this
country
it's all over the world
and we're about to go into an evening in
eight days can you believe that we're
about to go into an evening that i think
is going to have
a similar result and maybe even a bigger
margin
but a similar result and the same thing
is happening
you know a good writer very good writer
a
writer on politics but a lot of things
uh byron york
right would you rate him good right i
think he's good but i saw him this
morning and he wrote something that
they were asking who's going to win he
said i don't know because they only show
these fake polls
he said i don't know but i cover this
he's a great political guy and he he
said i go around and i cover this whole
thing
and i'm not only talking about the
rallies that trump has because he sets
them up you know we have to take the
space so we have to do
where organically there are rallies
of boats thousands of boats all over the
place
and cars and tractors and trucks
trucks thousands of them he said there's
never been anything like this he said
i've never seen anything like this
politically
there's such a spirit like i've never
seen he said you have these organic
and trump has nothing to do with them
but their rallies where truckers
get a thousand trucks in iowa they had
like 2 000 tractors on this massive
field he said i've never seen anything
like this
so i can't really tell you but i have
never seen and how about these rallies
nobody's ever had rallies like this you
might have
you might have a rally like this you
might have a rally like this
on the night before the election right
the night before the election but you'd
never have rallies these are massive
everyone
ohio was so big ohio if you would have
added up
inside and outside you had at least 50
000 people wisconsin
the same kind of thing but he said
forget those i'm talking about
where they just organically form nothing
to do with trump
and it's an amazing thing right it's an
amazing thing
it's an amazing so we have a spirit we
have a spirit and enthusiasm which is
the most important thing
we have a spirit and enthusiasm that's
even
far greater than four years ago we had a
lot we had a record
but we have much more because we've done
so much
nobody no administration has done in the
first three and a half years what we've
done
when you think we've rebuilt our
military we've gotten the big tax cuts
we've gotten the biggest regulation cuts
in history
i mean so many things right to try just
i'm just thinking right to try
where you can now as a patient you're
terminally ill you couldn't get anything
you'd have to travel
all over the world most people didn't
have money they'd go home and they'd die
now we have right to try where you can
get these advanced treatments that
haven't been fully approved
you're terminally ill but very hard to
get they've been trying to do it for 40
years
what we've done for the vets what we've
done for the vets
91 approval rate so
[Applause]
so there's more enthusiasm now
by far and we had look we were known
as that was the most enthusiastic
anybody has ever seen
a political campaign the deplorables
remember hillary
the deplorables she i heard that speech
she said
she said a second word irredeemable
right she said
the deplorables and the irredeemables i
thought irredeemables was worse but that
one didn't catch on
little did she know whoever wrote that
speech i want no part of them
because the next day i am a deplorable
i'm a proud deplorable right
it was the craziest thing but there has
never been a campaign like that
this one has much more enthusiasm the
difference is before i was a guy who was
successful who was saying
we're going to do this and this and this
but you know you're listening you say
okay
now we've done we have done according to
two of those people by the way that i
see there we have done
more than we promised like space force
we did space force i never talked about
space
right think of it we we
have now space force a sixth branch of
the new if the military
it's been 75 years since that happened
the air force right
now i realized when i was in office that
we needed it because i saw russia and i
saw china in particular
and i saw them and i said well we need
this and that's very hard to get
and we got it we did much more than we
even talked about doing
but the main thing is we did it we got
it done
and that's why there's even more
enthusiasm now than the worst four years
ago
that's a long speech let's get back to
the teleprompter
should we get back to the teleprompter
or just keep going
isn't it nice to have a president that
doesn't need a teleprompter
[Applause]
how about when they give sleepy joe the
questions they give him the questions
we're going to ask you this question
and then they give them answers and he's
reading the answer reporter
sir could you please ask what flavor ice
cream
do you have they never asked me a
question like that
what flavor do you have sir uh i have he
wasn't actually sure actually
i have vanilla and chocolate i said they
never asked me a question like that
even crazy 60 minutes you see it last
night she was so hostile to me
and with him it was softball but you
know what he did uh yesterday he
he called me you know he called me
george yesterday
he didn't remember my name i'm insulted
by it
i didn't know was i supposed to be happy
or was i supposed to be sad
he called me george and then i hear the
reporter sort of said no no no
it's not george donald
we can't have this look our country is
too important
president xi is a hundred percent char
putin 100
child kim jong-un north korea 100
sure we can't have this this is not a
game we're playing
if biden and the democrats socialists
are elected
they will raise your taxes bury your
regulations they will
bury you in regulations dismantle your
police department you see that
dissolve our borders wall is 400 miles
long now it's almost complete
almost complete and it's everything that
border patrol wanted we gave them their
ultimate wish list we said
let me see what you want how about
concrete planche
i like concrete plank it's cheap they
said
no sir we have to see through it we'd
like steel because it's stronger than
concrete
but we'd like concrete also so we have
the bars and then we have concrete in
the bars and then sir we'd like rebar in
the middle
so we have rebar in the middle no it's
really incredible and it's had a
tremendous impact it's the safest border
we've ever had now which was very good
time
and mexico is paying for the wall by the
way for those people
you notice you don't hear anything about
the wall anymore it used to be like
when they thought i couldn't get it done
it was every day
he is not going to be able to get it
done remember pelosi was fighting us
like crazy saying
walls are obsolete we don't need walls
we need drones to watch the people pour
into our country
we need a drone a thousand feet up so
that we can watch people
pour right in now we have drones too and
they work off the wall okay that's a
good combination but
but they were just going wild and then
once i got the financing and
this and that and then i won court cases
all over the place so we started
doing 10 miles a day so we're up to over
400
miles will be finished very soon but but
you don't hear about it anymore they
don't talk about the wall anymore
they want to confiscate your guns
terminate religious liberty
and pack the supreme court with radical
justices
who will shred the second amendment you
better get out and vote
and to defend our god-given freedoms i
nominated
amy coney barrett
it's going to be great she's gonna be
great she's gonna be there for a long
time
gonna be there for a long time and they
vote on her today you know tonight today
the democrats are saying that's a
terrible thing they do the same the
first one's not terrible
justice ginsburg said no he's the
president for four years
if somebody comes up in the fourth year
what's the difference she said of course
she was referring to clinton or
obama i guess right she perhaps wouldn't
have said it if it was me
but she did say it and that's the way it
is
and they would do the same can you
imagine schumer cry and chuck saying
you know what we think it's highly
unethical to appoint the supreme court
justice
radical left supreme court justice
because it's the fourth year
and we think therefore we won't do it
can you imagine that they would do it
the only difference is they'd do it
faster than we did it
okay joe biden has made a corrupt
bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination he has handed control
of his party over to the socialists
marxist and left-wing extremists
and if biden wins the flag-burning
radicals on the streets will be running
your government just like in portland we
want to go in you know we stopped them
in
minnesota minneapolis we stopped them
wasn't that a beautiful site
we should have been allowed to do it a
lot sooner in seattle you know we let
them know we're coming in
and the following like two hours later
they walked away
we were all set to go in i was sort of
unhappy that they left
they took over a big chunk of seattle
remember that but we let them after a
while you know because the state is
supposed to ask us and they weren't
going to
but we told them i'm sorry where's
hunter where is hunter he's he's making
he's he's trying to make a deal with a
foreign country to pay him 10 million
where's hunter remember the t-shirt
where's hunter i was right
thank you very much for that squares
this can only happen in pennsylvania
right
i was here for school
so they don't talk about hunter in the
news now you know that right
i give a lot of credit to the new york
post to endorse me on their cover today
but they don't talk about hunter because
they're not allowed to
because we don't really have freedom of
the press we don't okay
we don't have they have totally taken
this horrible scandal the second
biggest scandal in the history of our
country the first biggest was they spied
on my campaign
that's the biggest and they got caught
but the second is this and they won't
even
talk about it they won't talk about it
and the tech giants
will shut everybody down and you don't
even hear here's a guy who had no job
and now all of a sudden he's making
millions and millions of dollars a year
and they don't want to talk about it and
they know it's wrong but that's called
the opposite of freedom of the press
that's called the opposite and they
should be ashamed of themselves and you
know the beautiful thing
is that we have a voice and we're
allowed to talk to people
lots of people and two of those red
lights just went off
no it's i mean they're suppressing you
talk about suppression they're
suppressing
it's suppressing something i've never
seen honestly
nobody
nobody has ever seen anything like this
even i i mean i'm not a big fan
i i think press is incredible i think it
should be incredible
it's got such potential to be incredible
would be so good for our country
but even me i never heard of anything
like what's going on
where you're not even allowed to write
new york times i don't know if they've
ever written a story about it
washington post they totally don't write
here's a guy who stole
tens of millions he had no energy
experience
zero he knew less than this very young
woman up here
do you know anything about energy
because if you do you know more than him
no he had no experience whatsoever he
was dismissed
very unceremonially i mean look
he was he was well whatever you want to
call it it was a
it was a very sad it was a sad dismissal
so he gets out of play he gets out of
the he gets out of the military
got no job nothing and his father
becomes vice president
and he gets a job on barista barista
right
and it's a very uh you know that
questionable reputation place it's an
energy company
gets a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars a month
plus they say three million dollars up
front to be on the board of a company
nobody gets that
so he's on the board of charisma he then
goes and he gets
three and a half think of this three and
a half
million dollars from the wife of the
mayor of moscow
he gets three and a half million then he
goes to china he's
he's like a human vacuum cleaner he
follows his father
then he goes to china gets a billion and
a half to manage even though he's never
heard of managing money knows nothing
about it
and gets millions of dollars in fees and
then he goes for the big quinella but
that's where it sort of ended
he asked china to pay him 10 million a
year
because he wants to do introductions it
was an introductory fee
10 million a year and i think that's
probably at some place where they got
caught
but this is pure corruption and joe got
a piece of it because they
said 10 goes to the big guy now unless
they have another big guy he's not a big
guy to me he doesn't look too big
he looks like a big guy no he doesn't
look like a big guy
but 10 goes to the big guy another one
we're 50
and they consider that off limits you
can't can you imagine if that were me or
my kids
i mean it would be the biggest scandal
it's a disgrace and what they do is they
shut it down they will
not write anything about it i never
thought a thing like that could happen
i never thought it could happen it's in
a way it's a bigger story than the
corruption of biden itself
joe biden took five days off before the
debate because he wanted to practice and
he still lost
like biola
[Applause]
you don't want a president who takes
five days off to study for a debate
i mean you do it every day what are you
supposed to study for really when you
think about it
and now he's taking at least another
four or five days off
but no but i did hear the breaking news
today was he's going to make
the speeches i told you i want to go
here it's so exciting
so exciting when you're a president
you can't take a day off you got to work
you got to work you got to work really
hard
for the american people you got to work
and if sleepy joe ever got in he
wouldn't be in charge
the radical left will be in charge of
the party
they will do including fracking there
won't be any fracking you could forget
the frackers out there
enjoy your life but it won't be in the
life of fracking that's all over the
country not just in pennsylvania
because it will be run by the radical
left and the green new deal
which i thought at first was a hoax i
thought it was like the russia hoax okay
i thought it was a hoax
and it wasn't i don't think they believe
it it's so crazy
a hundred trillion dollars this election
day the people of pennsylvania must stop
the anti-american radicals by delivering
joe biden and the far left democrats a
thundering defeat
at the ballot at the ballot
whether you like hearing it or not joe
biden
is a corrupt politician he's a corrupt
politician
you don't do that you don't do that with
these countries
we could it would be so easy it's like
they raise all this money
300 million dollars and they're saying
oh trump is being outraged
i would be the greatest fundraiser all i
have to do is call all the wall street
guys call all the guys call
everybody i would get 5 10 15 20 25
million every time i made a phone call
but you know what i could never
basically deal with those companies
properly again
so i don't do it and we don't need the
money we got a lot of money for this
stuff we got another eight days to go
they had like 200 million dollars a lot
of it's small money you know 61
average small money that's never
happened to a republican before
but this way you don't have to sell your
soul when somebody gives you a lot of
money
it's you know not to say quid pro quo
i'm sure joe would never do a thing like
that you know
but the fact is he's making deals he's
making deals
i could do it much easier because i'm
much better at it if i wanted to be
and think of it i'm the president of the
united states calling the head of
goldman sachs goldman sachs
this is no i know i know them all i want
you to give me 25 million dollars i'm
running the campaign please give me 25
million they never report this stuff
and they would say where do we send the
check and we can have it there in one
hour sir
but i don't want to do that because i'm
compromised once you do that you
compromise
they're compromised they're compromised
the democrats want to destroy your
energy jobs in pennsylvania
well they're collecting for families but
in joe's case
all of this money that we talked about
on boards and everything else it's a
terrible thing
foreign companies he wants to send you
jobs to china while
his family rakes in millions of dollars
from the chinese
communist party that's what it is
i gave up a fortune to run for president
which is true i lost a fortune on this
deal this is
this is i lost uh i mean like
billions between what i lose and what i
didn't make i lost a hell of a lot of
money and you know what
it's the greatest decision i've ever
made because
we are doing things that nobody else has
ever been able to do
we're helping a lot of people we're
helping a lot of people
joe biden made a fortune by serving you
as vice president he made a fortune
biden will
sell the oval office just like he sold
the vice presidency
the corruption she said he already has
yeah in advance that's right the
corruption of politicians like biden and
it is corruption
is exactly why i ran for president i
really i ran for trade i hated the trade
deals i saw that years ago in michigan
they gave me the man of the year award i
said why are you allowing them to take
all of your car companies
and moving them to mexico and canada 32
of our companies were taken out i said
why are you doing that so it was for a
lot of reasons this one but it was also
for trade the trade was so crazy
and now the trade is really good biden
is the candidate of
big media big tech big donors i mean you
think about it
here i am here i stand right i am with
you
i stand here here's who i have against
me the democrat party
the rhinos from the republican party i
call them the stupid people
most of whom i beat because you know
they all represented one of the
candidates in the republican party
then they went they went sour i guess i
beat them really badly they've never
forgotten
but the rhinos big tech i have everybody
i guess
i have rhinos big tech i have very bad
republicans actually sometimes the bad
republicans are worse than the democrats
[Music]
and we have big tech and i stand here by
myself
and i say i am the only thing between
you
and chaos i am the only thing between
you and your second amendment
i am the only thing
between you and pro-life i'm the only
thing
i'm the only thing i'm by myself
i'm all by myself now we have some good
republicans but
i'm all but we we we have some
republicans that also go
it's a strange thing right how some of
them they just go off the track
and they always have this is not unique
to us they always have for some reason
we have some great ones we have some bad
ones too
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician if you
haven't noticed
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington
and the washington establishment it's
because i was elected to fight for you
and i have fought harder for you than
any president has ever fought
so we're joined by a couple of real
warriors that i'd like to introduce
congressman scott perry scott thank you
very much
warrior congressman
lloyd smucker
[Applause]
two great guys really fighters they're
warriors we had
some great fights that we've won haven't
we we have some great people in the
republican party
candidate for pennsylvania state
treasurer
stacy garrity stacey
vote for stacy you're doing well stacy
good
i heard you're doing great and chris cox
bikers for trump did you ever hear from
this guy
he was great i went you know chris says
thousands of bikers i don't know why the
hell the bikers like me so much but they
like
chris told me i might be at 99 to 100
but chris is great
and no matter where i go i have these
bikes thousands and thousands of bikes i
never saw
and i say come on in can you come in
there's no room for the firm right
they didn't want to come in they said
sir we're not here to listen to you
speak
we're here just to protect you we want
to protect you think of that
right
now when they say big joe that doesn't
work but that guy is big
thank you very much chris great job
you're doing it i appreciate it no it's
true he said no sir we're here for
and i felt so safe these guys tough guys
definitely tough
and they're sitting on those harleys
mostly i guess right there that
they felt good that was never my deal
okay
i like the limousine better i don't know
why
but you know they're gone boom boom and
i never felt safer it's true there was a
just a tremendous love that we had right
from the beginning right
four years ago right from the beginning
and it stayed that way too we're with
them all the way
we built the greatest economy in history
and now we're doing it again
we increased middle class family income
over six thousand dollars
more than five times the gains in all
eight years
under the previous administration
african-american unemployment hispanic
american unemployment asian-american
unemployment
unemployment for young people that
didn't have a high school education
they didn't have a diploma they had a
diploma
they had a diploma from mit where they
were first in their class it didn't make
any difference
every women did so great women
women women did great
they all reached the lowest levels ever
recorded
since april we created a record 11.4
million jobs
and under my leadership we achieved the
most secure border
in u.s history that's beautiful
walls help walls work don't they huh
remember
they said the wall is obsolete i said
now walt's not obsolete and a wheel is
not absolute everything else is obsolete
my opponent's insane immigration plan
would eliminate u.s borders by
implementing nationwide catch and
release
and i actually heard he said we want to
take down the wall don't you believe
this
take down the wall we will never let
that happen
we got to win this election this is this
is the most important we got to win this
election
no they want to take down the wall his
plan i don't think
you know what i don't think border
patrol would let him okay you want to
know that
i think border patrol would say mr
president we're not letting you get
anywhere near this wall mr president
his plan would also make every community
into a sanctuary city for violent
criminals
the biden harris harris said he like
harrison
the biden harris plan would also
increase refugees
700 this was the manifesto that was
agreed to with crazy bernie and
and uh biden right so biden and crazy
bernie agreed to the man
we caught the manifest 700 increase
the most dangerous places in the world
they would come in 700
i have a ban i was criticized for the
ban i said no if a country hates us
and if their people hate us and if they
want to do bad things to us
we're going to have a ban everybody
criticized me but i won
in the united states and now we don't
let them in
[Applause]
if it's okay by the great people of
pennsylvania we don't let them in
to our country we want people that will
love us
and work with us and be a great help to
us that's what we want
so we have a ban it was very
controversial when i put it in but it's
not
so controversial all you have to do is
look what happened the other day in
paris
and you'll see there's not so
controversial anymore people are very
happy that we have it
and we keep a lot of very bad people out
of our country
and nobody else would do that nobody
else would do that chris i guarantee you
that nobody else would do it
they pledged to terminate all national
security travel bans they wouldn't in
the band
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic
terrorism no thank you i'm keeping the
terrorist jihadist and violent
extremists
those terrible extremists the hell out
of our country if that's okay
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military by the way
all made in the usa we have the greatest
equipment the greatest missiles
we have the greatest rockets we have the
greatest jet fighter planes f-35
we have the greatest equipment anywhere
in the world our nuclear arsenal is
totally rebuilt or new
hope to god we never have to use any of
this equipment just hope we never have
to
by having it it's less likely we'll have
to use it sort of
that's the way it is that's the way it
is but we have the greatest
when i came in a highly overrated
general one of the most highly overrated
generals there are
said sir we don't have any ammunition
because we could have had a conflict as
you remember at the beginning
he said sir we don't have any ammunition
i said no president should ever hear
that again
and now we have so much ammunition you
won't believe
how much ammunition
we also passed va choice and va
accountability everyone said impossible
together
and exactly one year ago today we killed
the leader of isis
al baghdadi
and we took out the world's top
terrorists
solomani is dead salamani
killed a lot of people salamani i
withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal 150 billion dollars
1.8 billion in cash how about that
that's a lot of cash
1.8 billion not even nobody's ever even
heard of such a thing
1.8 billion five plane loads of cash
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
[Applause]
every president for decades they
campaigned on that
every president look at that that's nice
every president for decades campaigned
they said not so easy to do but i did it
instead of and i got the building built
right fast we got it built for a tiny
tiny little fraction of what it was
supposed to cost
instead of never-ending wars we are
forging peace in the middle east
you saw what just happened
you saw what just happened right sudan
yesterday sudan
uae united arab emirates
right bahrain and we have them stacked
up
stacked up they want to come in and we
did it the exact reverse as i've been
trying to do for 40 years i said that
one doesn't work
and it's all working out very well and
there's no blood in the sand
and they want to come in a vote for
republicans
is a vote for the american dream it's
very simple it is a vote for the
american dream you know
the republican party is the party of
abraham lincoln right
i always say you know when they start
saying this or that i said no no
it's very easy to be presidential i can
be more
presidential than any president in
history
with the possible exception of abraham
lincoln when he's wearing the hat right
actually doing this is much tougher than
being presidential
doing what i do is much tougher and if i
was presidential
perfectly presidential it'd be about
three people like obama had the other
day three people
and in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
which is already beginning
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
[Applause]
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment second amendment
we will end surprise medical billing
require price transparency the biggest
thing is price transparency you will see
goes into effect already signed i've
signed it january 1st the biggest thing
lower drug prices as i told you favored
nations losses
biggest decrease in the history why do
you see that when that kicks in
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
always
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
always
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Applause]
for years you had a president to
apologize for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
pennsylvania
i'm standing up
for the last four years you've seen me
fight for you
and now i am relying on you to deliver
a historic victory for our country
bigger even than four years ago by the
way could i ask you know pennsylvania's
no
it's known as a very late voting state
which is good which is fine
very late voting like election day very
unusual actually but i understand it
you want to make sure your vote is
counted you don't want the ballot hoax
because when you see they'll have so
many problems you know they throw away
ballots
if it has the name trump on it boom they
printed ballots some ballots i think 25
000 were printed for a certain state
it was missing one little thing to name
trump
so a lot of bad things happened but
pennsylvania's smart you vote late
who has voted raise your hand yeah
that's what happens this is going to be
a red way
who is going to vote
this is going to be and i'm glad you saw
the last debate
you know did you hear the number one
thing on google was how do i change my
vote did you know that
how do i change my vote something like
hashtag
did you hear that hashtag how do i
change my vote they watch the debate
i wanted remember i wanted that debate
to move way up you know because a lot of
people voted
by this crazy ballot deal where do you
see the mess
that thing is going to be in well even
your state
they can count them after the election
is over this is a major state
they want to count them so they don't
want poll watchers or they want to be
able to count votes after the election
is over
what does that mean we're going to wait
the whole country is going to wait
so we'll see how it all ends up it's all
in court it's all a hoax and let me tell
you something
the democrats know how crooked it is
they don't
and then they talk about he's not for
freedom he's not for freedom our
president is not for freedom
and he's not looking for an easy
transition and safety
what about the transition that i had
were you spied on my campaign
and you tried to take down the president
of the united states that didn't work
out too well
but they want a friendly transition
right jeffrey a friendly but you know
the only problem is
look at the transition they gave us they
fought us tooth and nail for years
russia russia russia 48 million spent on
mueller that whole hoax
48 million no conclu no collusion right
so no collusion 48 million dollars no
they want a friendly friendly first of
all here's the main thing
let's not lose and then we don't have to
worry about it
let's just win we won't lose so there's
nothing to talk about let's leave it
that way
no we want everything to be done
properly and we want it to be done
absolutely by the book and we want to go
absolutely by our great
constitution but you know what when they
start talking about this
friendly wonderful transition and then
you see what they put us through
it's really very hypocritical isn't it
huh
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain that very deep and very nasty
swamp
once and for all
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors and get your co-workers
even
get your boss say boss i wanna get you
out to vote
but get out and vote most important
election
ever i really believe that i never
thought i'd say it if you would have
told me i was going to say that
two years ago three years ago four years
ago i would have not believed it
from erie to easton from pittsburgh to
harrisburg
and from lebanon to right here in
lancaster
we stand on the shoulders of
pennsylvania patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
this is the state where founding fathers
declared american independence think of
it what you did
think of think of pennsylvania think of
it relative to our country so much has
happened so many important
events it's where the army weathered its
brutal winter at valley forge
where general george washington don't
worry we will not be taking down the
washington monument
[Applause]
cancel culture congressman there'll be
no cancer culture
now can you believe that they want wanna
they do i mean they actually had a
commission
the dc mayor one of the recommendations
is
lincoln jefferson washington memorials
let's take them out
and they didn't like mount rushmore
either okay
it's blowing right up now not gonna
happen no we stopped it you know i
signed
a document you play with any of our
statues or monuments
10 years in prison
it's amazing how that stopped all of a
sudden jeffrey has just stopped right
you don't see it anymore
where general george washington led his
men on a daring
mission across the delaware and when our
union was saved
by the great heroes of gettysburg
gettysburg think of that
what a place never fight uphill me boys
right that was robert and he said never
fight uphill he heard they were fighting
uphill
but they didn't have cell phones in
those days
they tried to get him to stop but they
fought uphill that didn't work out
think of that though gettysburg the
history this is the place where
generations of tough strong
pennsylvania workers mine the call work
the railroads
forged the steel that made america into
the greatest most powerful nation in the
history
of the world and where we are making it
far greater than it ever was we are
making it far greater this nation will
be greater than it ever was
and i so believe that
i so believe that proud citizens like
you
helped build this country and together
we are taking back our country
we are returning power to you the
american people that's what's happening
and they don't like that in washington
with your help your devotion and your
drive we are going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of pennsylvania
we have made america powerful again our
military
we have made america wealthy again your
stock markets your 401ks
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
[Music]
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you pennsylvania thank
you thank you
[Music]
young man there's no need to feel down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can hang out all
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
your dreams but you've got to know
this for one thing you know man
does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
[Music]
it's funny
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is